- If you wanted to get from here
in London to here in New York
in under two hours, you'd
need to be moving fast,
really fast, hypersonic to be precise.
And that's exactly the aim
of aviation startups,
Destinus and Hermeus.
Companies like these are aiming
to build passenger planes that will travel
at Mach 5 more than twice the speed
of Concorde, dramatically
reducing the amount
of time it would take to fly anywhere.
Now, while these companies
have made progress
developing new engines, conducting tests
and signing contracts with partners,
right now their hypersonic dreams
are not quite there.
So as always, we're going to look
at where these companies are now,
where they want to be in the future
and what they need to do to get there.
But before we get into
that, I want to explain
to you how these companies plan
on flying hypersonically.
Their aim is to create a new engine
by combining turbojets
with ramjet technology.
Now, if that sounds familiar,
you might have seen it
in "Top Gun Maverick".
- Transitioning to Scramjet.
- [Host] Albeit with a faster Scramjet.
But if you don't dunno
what any of that means,
I asked Hermeus's CEO to explain it
to me like I was a five year old.
- You compress air, you burn it,
and then you exhaust it through a nozzle
to generate thrust.
On the turbojet side,
you need a mechanical compressor
to compress the air and you need a turbine
to power the compressor.
So with a ramjet,
you compress it with a shockwave.
So it's naturally done just based
on the speed that you're going.
- [Host] That's why these companies plan
on using a combination of both engines,
a turbojet to take off
and get you fast enough or a ramjet
to kick in and take you hypersonic.
And ramjet technology isn't new.
It's actually been
proven to work years ago.
- What we demonstrated today is something
that we've been working on in the ground
for over 40 years.
- [Host] So now Destinus
and Hermeus are hoping to use that tech
to carry passengers.
- In 10, 15 years,
you can have the first passenger plane,
not big one, not like Boeing 777,
kinda small one like (indistinct).
- [Host] That's Mikhail
Kokorich, CEO of Destinus
who hopes to have
its 25 seat Destinus S aircraft ready
for commercial service by 2030.
And Hermeus aims to have
its 20 seat Halcyon aircraft
carrying paying passengers
by around the same time.
- We're not so naive to think
that we could do that right off the bat.
So we've laid out a
roadmap of three aircrafts
that will incrementally buy
down the technical risk
as well as the business risk.
- [Host] As for the ticket costs,
well that will be down to the airline.
But Hermeus told me
that much like Concorde,
it could be charged at a premium price.
But all of that is in the future.
And right now, both of these companies
are a long way from carrying passengers.
Both have been working
on that tricky turbojet ramjet problem
by taking existing engines
and modifying them.
Destinus has also managed
to fly some test flights albeit
with smaller scale models,
with smaller engines.
- After two and a half years,
we tested two prototypes.
We are building the Supersonic prototype
which will be the first supersonic
manned vehicle in Europe.
- And both companies
are using the knowledge
that they're gaining
from pursuing hypersonic flight
to sell products and services.
Hermeus plans to use
its development aircraft
as a test bed for the US military,
signing a $60 million deal
with the US Air Force.
- So for the flight test services that
that conducts we'll provide those
as a service to our customers
be they the US government allied partners
or industry.
- But in order for these
companies to progress
from engine testing
to commercial hypersonic flight,
they're gonna have to find the solutions
to a lot of unanswered questions.
For starters, there are physics questions
like how to handle the
extreme temperatures
as the aircraft hits its top speed.
There's also questions around
how passengers will
feel while accelerating
to Mach 5, because while these aircraft
won't go off like a rocket,
there still will be a sustained period
where you're accelerating.
- So, the climb and acceleration period
on a hypersonic aircraft will last,
I'd say 12 to 15 minutes depending
on the trajectory.
- [Host] Then there's
operational questions
like how to avoid creating
a sonic boom over land
and how that affects your
roots and scheduling.
Destinus has told me
they'd still be quicker
than most flights, even if they had
to travel extra mileage to avoid land.
- For hypersonic, when
you fly in 5,6 Mach,
it's like two hours and a half.
It's the opposite.
It's still extremely fast comparing
with the direct flight of 12 hours.
- There's even questions
around how regular
these flights would need
to be to become economically successful.
After all, it's great saying
that you can fly from London to New York
in 90 minutes, but that's not much use
if the flight doesn't depart
for another six hours.
And let's not forget,
we're now more connected
in the air than we've ever been before.
And that means that the number
of people willing to
pay a premium to travel
at ultra fast speeds could be lower
than it used to be.
All of that means that the economics
around hypersonic flight
is still wildly uncertain.
So for hypersonic flight to take off,
these companies are going to have
to develop their engines, flight test
and certify their aircraft,
receive regulatory approval
for their sonic boom
creating flight, establish route,
prove that the experience can be safe
and comfortable and then
prove there's a market
for hypersonic flight.
That's a long road to be able
to carry paying passengers.
So while these companies say
that this technology might be right
around the corner,
if you want to travel
somewhere hypersonically fast,
you might have to wait a while first.
(upbeat music)